Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's. Welcome to another Read Your Genes podcast.
We're going to go over genetic questions that you send in.
So let's jump right into those questions. We have several for today.
First one, are there genetic factors in Lyme disease?
Well, one could say there's genetic factors in every disease.
Are there, is, is Lyme disease have a genetic cause?
No, that in fact, there's very huge, few diseases that have a specific genetic cause.
There may be pieces of the disease that, you know, make the disease of genetic defects can make the disease worse.
And certainly with Lyme disease, I was involved with a study a number of years ago, though, that there show just a correlation with people with chronic Lyme disease and different sets of genes.
Well, I've seen that with cancer as well. There's certainly a correlation with certain genetic defects in cancer.
How much is that correlated? We don't know. For instance, upon one gene, which is a defect in your liver detox pathways and your phase two pathways specifically are highly core correlated with different cancers.
One pathway to defects are correlated with Lyme disease as well, and it has to do with the ability to detoxify.
So if you have a lesser or slower detox pathways, a lesser ability to detoxify the lesser rate of detoxification, you're certainly going to be more susceptible to a lot of different diseases.
Biotoxins like Lyme disease, there's other genetic correlations with people with more Lyme brain type symptoms. There's genetic correlations with even the HLA genes with people that end up having more sensitivities food sensitivities and such with these diseases.
But there certainly isn't a specific gene or you have this gene, you are more susceptible to having Lyme disease because you have this gene defect.
There's nothing that specific. Remember, most genetic defects, what a person has issues with that gene, it's more of an epigenetic concern, meaning that there's lifestyle things that they could change.
That's a whole idea why we want to run your genes, why it's wise to get your genes run is because then you can change lifestyle factors, you make lifestyle changes, epigenetic changes based upon, hey, here's your genes, you have a little bit higher likelihood of having these types of issues, you know, it gives you some incentives and motivation to make lifestyle changes.
But there's not that many, there are of course, there's different diseases that are completely genetically caught and there's a genetic cause to them.
Most of our, you know, diseases or acquired diseases are not, don't have a specific genetic cause, there's just factors.
Why do people get genetic defects? That's an interesting question. That's up for debate. Some people believe that there's, we develop genetic defects over time as a race.
They come to deal with different environmental things that would be in the case of, you know, different genetic defects actually can be beneficial, like on the genes for dairy, if you have those defects, you tend to be able to break to create more lactase, which is the enzyme to break the lactose, so you end up with less lactose intolerance issues.
Most genetic defects, we wouldn't say are necessarily positive ones, meaning that, you know, they don't create benefits. Most of them create possible hindrances to health.
So, from another perspective that is that we develop genetic defects because of our environment, so we're exposed to different toxins or pesticides or chemicals that damage our genes.
And then, you know, so that could be a genetic defect that I have acquired, meaning that I was born with, let's say, what are called wild type genes, no defect in a certain gene family.
And then, because of my exposure to pesticides, that what I was in my teens, that damaged those genes, now I have a singular legal or double effect. And now I would pass them to my children. So, if I, you know, had children, post having a genetic defect, now my children will receive that genetic picture from me combined with their mother.
Then the chance of them having a singular legal or double effect goes out because of my defect. So, we can, we, of that, we, we inherit genetic defects from our parents, and then we could acquire genetic defects from our environment.
And if we acquire a genetic defect from our environment, typically some sort of chemical, you know, you know, damage because of some chemical pesticide, you know, environmental toxin, heavy metal toxicity or something that gets inside the cell and damages our genes.
And that's it, a prior defect, then we will pass that on to our progeny from that point on.
What's the difference between a one or a two under the report? I think this person's looking at whether it's a singular legal defect or a double legal defect. And I have some videos on this that help explain it, but it's simply, it just means that if you have a blank, there's, there's nothing there. And on the report that we give you, I don't think it has a zero.
It just doesn't, it's blank or it's a water or two. It's blank. That means you're at the wild type, you don't have any genetic defects on that specific gene.
That's typically good. That's what you want. If you have a one, you have a singular legal defect, you have a chance that, especially if there's epigenetic factors going on that that gene is not going to work quite as well as if you had a blank, if you had no defects. And if you have a two, that means you have a greater chance of that gene.
Not functioning as well as if it was a one or a blank. I don't ever want anybody to take that all because I have a two on the MTHFR677 gene. Now I don't make Bethel groups that I'm doing for life that's just only wrong information that has been fed in the public. That's just not true. It doesn't mean that that gene doesn't work. It doesn't mean that you're condemned to having problems.
This means that the chance that that gene works is less effective is really what we're looking at. So all these epigenetic factors, what you look at your genes, like, well, because I have these defects, or I have a lot of defects, ones and twos in that family of genes, then we might be best to support that with dietary lifestyle changes, maybe some nutritional changes.
So a blank means that you have no defects. A one means you have a single allele defect at a two, which typically is what we would consider the worst is that you have defects on both those alleles of the genes. So there's two alleles and all your gene and your genes that we're looking at. And you want to have a blank, but most of them. It does stay in the report, you know, like, for instance, on the dairy genes. It's better. You have
a defect, confess it's a beneficial gene to have a defect. And there's some other ones that are like that, but it states that in the report. All right, thanks for being a part of our reader, James podcast. And we'll see you in a couple weeks.